Speaker 1: Okay, let's now talk about Donald
Trump's plan that he has made clear is his
plan to announce his candidacy on Tuesday at Mar a
Lago. Donald Trump talking about initially that he
might announce in Ohio. He then decided that that
is not what he is going to do. And then in Ohio,
he actually said, we are going to make the
announcement on November 15th. So let's go
through this step by step, starting with what
Trump first teased in Florida a few days ago
about Ohio. Take a listen.
Speaker 2: I will probably
have to do it again, but stay tuned.
Speaker 1: Okay. So then the crowd. Cheers
for a while. Then Trump says the following.
Speaker 2: That's pretty good. Thank you.
Stay tuned to tomorrow night.
In the great state of Ohio,
tuned. We have a big win, a big rally there.
Speaker 1: Okay. So then people thought he's going
to announce tomorrow. He's going to announce
tomorrow. Did not happen because tomorrow,
which was Monday. Donald Trump decided
the announcement will be next Tuesday.
Speaker 2: I'm going to be making
a very big announcement on Tuesday.
November 15 at Mar a Lago in Palm Beach, Florida.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So as recently as yesterday, Donald Trump
was appearing on TV and still saying,
I'm going to do it. This is the latest.
Speaker 4: All right. Well, we're talking
about your announce. I do want to bring
up something a lot of people been talking
about. You've had so many rallies.
Speaker 1: This is not sped up,
by the way. This is normal speed.
Speaker 4: After your huge rallies
that we've seen. We've covered many of them
here on Newsmax. But you said that you're
going to do this at Mar a Lago on November 15th.
Why the significance of announcing at Mar a Lago?
Speaker 2: Well, I actually would have preferred
doing it at a rally, but I didn't want to take
away from JD. I didn't want to take away from
anybody else that, you know, was at the particular
rally. Even Marco's rally was so great. It was
an unbelievable in Miami. Right. And I would
have preferred it. And then I said, you know, I
take away I also take away maybe from the day,
which is today, because, you know, you're talking
about a big announcement. So I just felt that
maybe it was better off doing it where it's by
itself a little bit. And it's just a few days,
actually, one week, exactly one week later. And a
lot of people are going to be there. But I really
like the idea of doing it at a rally because,
you know, when you have 40, 50,000 people and
you make that kind of an announcement and they're
all saying, do it, do it, they're screaming less,
they'd do it. But so what I did last night, I
said, I'm going to do it. We're going to make
a really, I think, statement that people
are going to be very happy about. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So the question now becomes, do the
results from last night change this plan? If
you're Trump, I don't think they do because Trump
is the endless narcissist, as we all know. I think
you can't sit Trump down and say, listen,
sir, as he always claims, people say to him,
you engaged, you engaged, you endorsed Tudor
Dixon. She lost badly. You endorsed Dr. Oz,
he lost you endorsed Doug Mastriano. He lost
you endorsed Blake Masters and Kerry Lake. TBD,
TBD. We don't know what's going on there. You
endorsed Herschel Walker. As of this moment,
he's losing. It will probably go to a runoff. And
then who knows what's going to happen? Who knows
what's going to happen? It's not great. And sure,
you endorse like 100 incumbents and they won,
but incumbents tend to win. That's not really a
big deal. Maybe you should consider not running.
I don't know that. Even if you show Trump the
numbers I just showed you in the last segment
and show Trump what folks since the last segment,
I think Ron DeSantis has potentially even gained
a little bit. And you show Trump. Listen, the
betting markets increasingly say it is going to
be Ron DeSantis, not you, if this is a contested
nomination. I don't even know that in that case,
you necessarily can convince Trump not to do
it. It is clear that what was previously a
silent feeling within some of the Republican Party
that Trump is bad for the party is becoming a more
publicly acknowledged feeling. Whether it actually
changes Trump's plans next week, I don't know if
indeed the announcement happens. We will cover it
live and make sure, folks, this this is the start
of an insane two year period at minimum. Please
make sure you subscribe to our YouTube channel.
More than 3 million people watch our clips and
don't subscribe. We need everybody on board for
what's coming over the next two years and the
defense of the democracy that we must carry out.
Make sure you're subscribed on YouTube. We're
going to take a quick break and be right back.